just a minute from the history and
biography room Cokie Roberts of ABC News
will kick off the festival discussing
her most recent book on women and the
Civil War book TVs live coverage of the
15th annual National Book Festival
begins now
[Music]
well thank you all for being here it's
such a great crowd here so so early in
the morning on a holiday weekend so my
name is Tim Collins and I work for Wells
Fargo and we've been a sponsor of the
Book Festival now for the last five
years so I'm just going to make a couple
of brief remarks until we get and then
let you guys get onto the good stuff
here but wanted to tell you why we're
involved with the Book Festival yes we
are a very large financial institution
but we'd like to think of ourselves as a
community bank and we are really
involved with the communities and where
that we serve both nationally and
locally we we volunteer lots of our team
members volunteer we donate more on
board on community boards and so when we
looked at the book fest of all it's such
a great opportunity in such a community
event on on both the local level here in
the DC area and certainly representing
the national community as well and
second reason was we are really involved
in education we have a program I'll give
you an example a program called reading
first which involves our team members
partnering with schools at the preschool
Kay 1st and 2nd grade level and go in
and give people give kids books and read
to them aloud in the schools and what we
find is that when kids on their first
book their interest in reading really
takes a quantum leap so it's a great
program we have donated more than a
million books and have team members
volunteer and almost 2 million hours of
volunteer time with people in programs
like that so enough about that I just
want to tell you what some things that
we're doing today that are kind of fun
and contributing to the event there's a
stagecoach outside where we have a long
history going back to the stagecoach
which predates the Transcontinental
Railroad which was mr. Roberts just got
to talk a little bit about in our book
and we have a stagecoach out here we
have a stagecoach downstairs in in Hall
B and then we also have a lot of other
fun activities we have a reading program
reading first program going on where we
are going to actually give kids books
and so we're will be reading aloud in
English Spanish and American Sign
Language and those kids that participate
in that event will also have the
opportunity to get a Wells Fargo's flush
pony as well and then we're also going
to be doing our together experience
which is a virtual reality experience
it's really cool it may not be your
thing but it's worth it's worthwhile to
at least go by and check it out because
it's a pretty fun experience so with
that I am going to turn it over to John
Haskell from the Library of Congress to
introduce Cokie thank you and have a
great day
[Music]
good morning I work at the Congressional
Research Service which probably a lot of
you know about and heading one of the
research divisions I was not given the
toughest assignment at the festival to
introduce Cokie Roberts it's mostly
telling you things you already know so
I'll say a few of those things she's
currently the senior news analysts are
one of the senior news analysts at NPR
among her many distinctions
she has three Emmy Awards Cokie also
received the living legend award from
the Library of Congress she's the author
of several books most recently Capitol
Dame's the Civil War and the women of
Washington by the way she'll be signing
that directly after this event she'll
have to rush down to the lower level the
book sales shop so you'll have to make
way for her to get down there when she's
done I'm gonna add one personal thing
from those of us who spent much of their
lives in the heartland of the country in
the pre-internet era many of us relied
on Cokie whether it was NPR or an ABC TV
as a unique source and I mean unique of
reasoned and balanced analysis on the
politics of issue and issues of the day
and she continues to provide that
service but speaking for me and many
many other people were very grateful
that she did that service for us and
continues to do that service please help
me welcome Cokie Roberts
thank you
thank you and thank you all for being
here on this Labor Day weekend I think
this book festival is one of the
greatest things that happens year in and
year out hundreds of thousands of people
showing up to celebrate books and to buy
them what a concept and and children and
families usually my grandchildren are
with me but I'm going to I'm going to
catch a plane and go see them in a
minute but it is it is a wonderful event
and the the fact is is that I write
these history books often many of the
characters in my history books are
political wives and it was a political
wife who started this book festival of
his Laura Bush who went to the fabulous
librarian of Congress Jim Billington and
said I did a Texas Book Festival can we
do one in Washington and and it shows
you what a fabulous legacy political
Wives throughout our history have left
here in Washington so that makes it even
more delightful for me to be able to
participate in it and also by the way we
should just say that the volunteers at
this festival are the heroes because
or I guess by and large the Shiro's
because there's no way that this this
could go on without these wonderful
hundreds of volunteers so thank you all
very much for what you do I had written
other history books about women in
history and I never was going to write
about the Civil War first of all all of
my ancestors fought on the losing side
and and so I didn't really have any
interest in it and secondly it's an
awful war it's a horrible horrible time
in our history we've lost more than
600,000 Americans and it's a failure of
the political system that that we
couldn't that these politicians could
not get to emancipation without war and
as somebody who covers politics and
cares about politics that to me was so
dispiriting that I really did not want
him write about it but my publisher had
other ideas and and was pretty clear
that I was writing a book about the
Civil War so I started to think about
that but I actually had absolutely no
idea what that book was going to be you
know I knew it would be about women
there are plenty of the others and I
know people who say to me why do you
write about women huh I mean
seems fairly obvious to me but no but
aside from the fact that I'm in a skirt
I do think that the other half of
humankind should have books written
about them but
[Music]
and I would actually argue that history
is not accurate without knowing what the
rest of the world was up to but so I
knew it was about women and I knew that
I would make great discoveries I knew
that I would find wonderful women's
letters that would just delight me I
have to say you know the men's letters
particularly in the founding period but
throughout our history are so studied
and edited and ready for publication
that they read as though they were
written by those bronze and marble
statues right whereas the women's
letters are just letters you know
they're funny and they're Frank and
they're and they're truthful there's a
concept and they and they and they'll
tell you the whole story you know in the
same letter you'll read about well maybe
we should go to war with France but you
know I need my new hat that I left at
home and so and so's having babies and
all too often losing them and here's
what the economic situation is you get
the full picture of society and life
through women's letters and and you find
them because most of them have never
been published and you find these other
lis delightful things
my favorite still remains one for my
second history book ladies of Liberty
about the early republic and it was
written by Louisa Catherine Adams John
Quincy Adams wife and it was written
when he was Secretary of State and she
was running his campaign for president
she called it her vocation to get him
elected president and she wrote these
wonderful gossipy letters home from
Washington to John Adams Abigail had
died here's Abigail by the way and she
had died and John was lonely and so the
reason wrote these letters home and this
particular letter was from the Year 1820
and it was the year the Missouri
Compromise and so because of the
hammering out the compromise a Congress
stayed in session much longer than you
and so finally they go home and in July
Luiza goes to a meeting of the trustees
of the Orphan Asylum that Dolly Madison
had established after the British
Invasion in 1814 and she gets there and
one of the other trustees says to her
we're going to need a new building and
Louisa says why what are we needed a
building for and the woman says I'm
quoting the session had been very long
the fathers of the nation had left 40
cases to be provided for by the public
and our institution was the most likely
to be called upon to maintain this
illness at progeny Congress had left 40
pregnant women behind and they were only
like 187 members of Congress and I mean
some of them might have been recidivist
I don't know but the and so she was up
in arms and she says I recommended a
petition to Congress next session for
that great and moral body to establish a
founding institution and should
certainly move that the two additional
dollars a day which they have been given
themselves as an increase in pay may be
appropriated as a front or the support
of the institution it doesn't get any
better than that I mean it's just when I
found that letter I was in ecstasy and
and then it did turn out that one of the
one of the great letter writers that I
found for this book the Civil War book
was her daughter-in-law Abigail Brooks
Adams who was married to Charles Francis
Adams and she came to Washington when he
was briefly in Congress before he went
off to be the Union ambassador to the
court of st. James through the war and
she wrote these wonderful feisty letters
home you know calling President Buchanan
a heavy old toad you know
saying you know the Senate behaved like
children and silly ones at that I could
get behind that one and but then my
personal favorite again was I would
advise any young woman who wishes to
have an easy quiet life not to marry and
Adams so I knew that the letters
whatever I found would be wonderful but
I still didn't know what the book was
and so I started thinking about my own
growing up here in Washington after
World War two and at that point the mall
was covered with what were called
temporary buildings
I actually remember as a very little
girl asking my mother what temporary
meant because the buildings didn't seem
to be going anywhere and and they were
basically Quonset huts that they were
very ugly they've been since been
replaced by those ugly buildings on
Independence Avenue but they but they
were a physical manifestation of how the
war had increased the role of government
it actually started as well we won them
World War two and how it had made
Washington's place in the country a very
different place than it had been at the
beginning of the century I also of
course knew the stories of Rosie the
Riveter and the government girls coming
to Washington during the war and I knew
that the the role of women during the
war had promoted women's rights after
the war the Republicans have put the e
ra in their platform in 1940 but it took
the war to get the Democrats to do it in
1944 and then the movement towards equal
rights again coming out of the
experiences of the world so I started
wondering well maybe that's maybe that's
it
maybe the Civil War had a similar impact
on women's lives and on the role of
Washington in society so I stood in the
country and so I started researching
that
and I turned out that yes in fact that
was exactly the case and and so that's
the book and it was just fascinating to
learn about it because it's it's as much
a history of Washington in the period as
it is a history of the women and as
somebody who's lived here all my life in
addition to Louisiana
it was very of great interest to me
and some of these women are women that
you know of like Clara Barton and
Dorothea Dix but you probably don't know
all about them and and some of the
things that they did were absolutely
remarkable Clara Barton had come here to
work in the government she worked in the
Patent Office and she actually made as
much as men for a period of time but
then during the war government girls did
show up in the same way that they did in
World War two mainly it was women coming
to to make a living with their husbands
or the men in their lives gone but then
it coincided with Congress passing the
bill to allow the printing of greenbacks
to finance the war and then as now the
money comes off the printing presses in
great huge sheets of bills it's a lot of
fun to watch if you've never seen it go
but now of course it's all cut up into
individual bills by Machine then it took
women sitting there with scissors
cutting out bill by bill by bill and the
treasurer of the United States General
Skinner said you know women are just
better with scissors than men arm
he also allowed us how he could pay them
less which was something that many of us
experiences in our own lives but then
then rosie the riveter the equivalent in
my view of the women who worked in the
arsenals which they did around the
country but here in Washington there was
it was mainly very young and very poor
women who worked in the Arsenal and
there was this horrendous Arsenal
explosion that killed a couple of dozen
of these girls and the day after the
newspaper the story was just awful to
read of them pulling the tarp off of the
charred bodies and they were really
basically unrecognizable and the
reporter said they were trapped in their
hoop skirts and you could see these 19th
century mid-century women working in
this very dangerous job in this broiling
hot Arsenal and being proper in their
hoop skirts thousands of people showed
up for the funeral led by the President
and the Secretary of War and formed a
procession going to the Congressional
Cemetery where there is a monument to
them recognizing their tremendous
contribution to the war effort and as I
say then there were women that you do
know about like like Clara Barton and
and Dorothea Dix they were also women
journalists who came to town again some
of them came before the war one of them
was grace Greenwood I mean Jane Smith
some who was somewhat the fiercest of
among them she was an abolitionist and a
suffragist and she was the first woman
allowed to write from the Senate press
gallery but she was soon kicked out of
the Senate press gallery for writing
vicious truths which
well she wrote that Daniel Webster was a
drunk and and the men didn't like that
and again it reminded me a lot of my own
experiences but there were activists
there were orders there were all these
fascinating women who who thrived during
the war in Washington and the reporters
came in large numbers
Dhar Thea Dix was here before the war
lobbying in Congress and she was so
influential that she was actually given
a little alcove in the Senate library by
the Senate from which to do her lobbying
and while she was here she established
st. Elizabeth's and then she went off to
other places when she failed at the bill
she was trying to get through Congress
it was vetoed by President Pierce but
she then came back for the war and
brought herself into the Surgeon General
and said that she would be the
superintendent of female nurses there
were no female nurses she she created
that and opened the profession to women
it really had not been women's work to
be nurses with the exception of of
Catholic nuns and she was a a formidable
figure who the whole medical profession
of course was closed to women there were
just a couple of female doctors in the
country at the time one of them was a
surgeon Mary Walker who again came to
Washington and presented herself to be
to work for the Union Army she was not
hired she worked as a volunteer and then
in the course of her work during the war
she was eventually hired she was
captured she had such horrific
experiences that she is still still the
only woman to have won the medal of
honor was Mary Walker during the Civil
War
by the time Dorothy addicts died by the
way she had created a hundred mental
more than a hundred mental hospitals
around the world including in Japan
meaning she had to travel by herself
there Clara Barton but you probably know
about Clara Barton this is what drives
me completely nuts about history books
particularly textbooks is Clara Barton
founded the American Red Cross really
was it hard did anything go before that
you know was what it was involved there
well of course a great deal was involved
she as I say came as a government worker
then did heroic work during the war as a
nurse and a supplier and then went to
Europe after the war and discovered the
Red Cross and came back and lobbied for
two decades to get the Geneva
Conventions ratified by the Senate and
when they finally did ratify them it was
with the American Amendment which she
wrote which says that the Red Cross
could go to natural disasters as well as
to war zones so anytime you see the Red
Cross and after a flood or a hurricane
or an earthquake anywhere in the world
it's because Clara Barton when she then
went back to Geneva as the American
representative got the American
amendment adopted by the International
Red Cross so there was a lot involved in
founding the American Red Cross but I of
course was most interested in because of
because I mean in the political women
and and I got to know a lot of them very
well and I liked a lot of them a lot one
who I really very much enjoyed getting
to know was Varina Davis Jefferson
Davis's wife him not so much but
she she was here as as the wife of him
is a senator and a cabinet officer and
all the women of Washington after Dolly
Madison died which was not until 18-49
really were vying to be the chief belle
and they described themselves as Belles
one of them who I write about wrote a
book about herself cause a Belle of the
50s and so they all knew each other they
basically all liked each other even
though they vied and one of the women
who they all liked enormous Lee was
Adele Cutts who was dolley Madison's
great niece and then she married Stephen
Douglas the senator of course defeated
Abraham Lincoln and the famous
lincoln-douglas debates and Farina Davis
was furious that this was happening and
she wrote to her mother and this is why
women's letters are so wonderful
she says the dirty speculator and party
trickster broken and health by drink
with his first wife's money buys an
elegant well-bred woman because she is
poor and her father is proud but then
marina says it's a good thing there's a
new water system coming to Washington
so that's barring his wife's olfactories
Douglass may watch a little oftener if
he doubt his acquaintance will build
larger rooms with more perfect
ventilation
you don't learn from the men that
Stephen Douglas thinks so it's great she
she when she did go off to Richmond to
be the first lady of the Confederacy
much to her dismay she stayed in close
touch with her friends here particularly
Elizabeth Blair Lee of Blair House and
Lizzie Lee wrote wonderful wonderful
letters her her brother Montgomery Blair
was in the cabinet of other brother
Frank Blair was in the Congress her
father Fred Frances Preston Blair was of
course the big adviser to Lincoln but
her husband Samuel Phillips Lee who was
a cousin of robert e lee was in the
Union Navy and because he was in the
Navy she wrote to him almost every day
and we have her letters the wartime
letters are published the rest are at
Princeton and and they are just utterly
delightful letters and she and marina
stayed in touch through the war she was
also one of the few people who
befriended Mary Lincoln not easy to do
and Mary Lincoln came to town at a tough
time that was basically a southern town
they didn't like Abraham Lincoln and
they thought she was women here thought
she was kind of a rough Westerner which
was not fair but that was the assessment
she then made life harder for herself by
being a difficult person and at one
point she was accused of leaking the
president's State of the Union message
and there was a congressional
investigation of the first lady's
private communications
she she had a personal servant - it was
the servants you know carry the lady's
bag employed and she was accused of
leaking it to the New York Herald either
in exchange for favorable publicity or
in exchange for money or because she was
having an affair depending on the rumor
of the moment but she was not a
well-liked person and and after the
president was shot the only person she
really had become friendly with was
Elizabeth Keckley her dressmaker who was
really much more than a dressmaker she
was an artist she was a couturier she
was written about as a great great
personage and and Mary Lincoln's and the
lighthouse for a couple of months just
in in crazy out of her mind
after the president shot and mrs.
Keckley is there with her she then takes
her back to Chicago all of that and then
Elizabeth Keckley wrote a tell-all book
I mean you know nothing changes and it
ended her relationship with mrs. Lincoln
and it actually ended her business too
because others were worried she might
write similar books but she but she was
then able to do which she was very
interested in which was basically social
work when enslaved people started
showing up in Washington trying to free
themselves before emancipation and then
after emancipation she saw she was a
former slave herself and she saw the
terrible circumstances and so she
started what was called the contraband
relief Association which became
Freedmen's relief Association and and
she was very involved in getting people
to help these desperately poor people
because she did have the contacts and
was able to raise money and that was
what you started to see was that the
people who had been behind
the scenes or have been doing other
things we're now coming forward as the
war ended and so Virginia clay who had
been the wife of an Alabama senator and
a delightful flirt in the pre-war period
she's the one who wrote the book about
herself a Belle of the 50s became a
great suffragists and was suddenly on
platforms after the war with Horace
Greeley and mrs. William Lloyd Garrison
people that had fought her husband
bitterly in the period leading up to the
war enduring the war but but she had
because of her experiences during the
war felt that she could come forward and
be someone herself and use her own voice
to promote a cause that had not occurred
to her before the war of arena Davis
after Jefferson Davis died
long-drawn-out difficult situation we've
been in jail accused of being one of the
lincoln conspirators she worked to get
him out of jail that's another thing
these women showed up in the White House
all the time they just go marching into
the White House and tell off the
president whomever he was I mean I am so
jealous I can't tell you
I mean Andrew Johnson let Virginia
Clay's husband out of jail just to make
her go away you know and it is pretty
remarkable with the any rape verinha
Davis got Jefferson Davis out of jail -
just didn't work so well for her but she
then he finally died and she she decided
to move to New York to be a reporter now
mainly she wanted the money she had to
make a living but also she wanted the
freedom and there was a big scandal that
the first lady of the Confederacy was
moving to New York and she had always
been a little bit - to Olive complected
for a perfect southern belle and so she
wrote to her daughter and said I am free
Brown in 62 I'm gonna move wherever I
want to do so while she was in New York
she befriended Julia Graham and it was
page 1 in every newspaper in the country
which is another great thing now you can
get these newspapers online the Library
of Congress has a wonderful site
chronicling America and and there they
were and and what they knew they were
doing was bringing about reconciliation
and and that's what a lot of these women
were involved in in their own voices
after the war was over and so you see
the tremendous impact that it had on
their lives and on the role of women in
America going forward and in fact Clara
Barton said at a memorial day again
something established by the women to
try to bring about reconciliation the
Memorial Day celebrations she she said
at one of her addresses at a Memorial
Day celebration in the 1880s she said
because of the war woman was at least 50
years in advance of the normal position
which continued peace would have assured
her so that's that's these women these
are the capital dames
they were remarkable people I
getting to know them I know you will too
thank you very very much for being here
and I'd be delighted a few questions
[Music]
are there microphones at the front of
each aisle and the folks here would very
much appreciate it if you'd come to the
microphones because they are taping this
or whatever one does these days
digitizing whatever so yeah good morning
and thank you so much for these
wonderful remarks and I am fascinated by
Dorothea Dix is lobbying career yeah
because I've looked at the scholarship
and at that point in time that would be
a very public and non-traditional role
for women and in fact a lot of Sanja
lists Times article from 1875 said women
as lobbyists could not you know work the
halls of Congress without taint and so I
just went I'm just so fascinated can you
share any more with us about Dorothea
Dix or women Lobby but she could do it
without taint because she was already so
well known by the time she showed up in
Washington at the bill that she was
trying to get through was to put aside
millions of acres of federal land for
the impoverished in the mentally ill and
she'd get it through one con one house
of Congress one year another house of
Congress another year she finally did
get it through both houses of Congress
and President Pierce said that this was
a state it was up to the states to
support them the impoverished and so he
vetoed it but but she was immune from
the normal things but the tape that
you're talking about was definitely
there and I do write about it
women lobbyists were considered maybe
exchanging some favors for the votes and
there was some of that with women
government workers to that because to
get the job they are this is one of the
reasons the civil service was created
because to get the job a congressman had
to recommend them and sometimes he would
demand something in return
and so it always had a little whiff
about it and but they they still did him
they still did those jobs and there were
lots of women Lobby
after the war no thank you yes good
morning hi who would you put on the ten
or 20 I know you know I have a really
hard time with this and part of the
reason for it is that the women just
didn't have the same kind of power as a
Benjamin Franklin or a Abraham Lincoln
but I can make a good case for Clara
Barton she she's not somebody you'd want
to hang with frankly you know she was
very worthy but but you know an
earthquake hits Nepal and the Red Cross
is there and that's all because of her
and that's true this many years later so
I can make that case to change the
subject too much but I sort books for a
inner-city library that wonderful used
to then fundraise and I came across a
book that I actually paid fifty cents
for our Haggadah oh yes yes
so in two generations of my family I now
have three major religions it's America
America yes is there a happy ending
no hell we're still married it would be
49 years this week so but our Hagaddah
was a book that paid the Passover Seder
that Steve and I have hosted and I've
cooked at our house for the last 47
years and and it is it is a Hagaddah
written for interfaith marriages yeah
good morning I have enjoyed all three of
your books on humans history thank you
and I was wondering if you were going to
continue the journey up yes
I don't know how necessarily people keep
saying to me what's your next project
and this book almost killed me
I keep saying it's like saying mrs.
Roberts you just had triplets when's the
next baby coming you know and so I'm not
exactly sure what the next project is I
have things rattling around here but the
immediate one is so I did and I was here
last year at the festival with the
children's book of founding mothers
which is this wonderfully wonderfully
illustrated book illustrated by Diane
good there's a call to cut metal one
winter and it's a beautiful book and so
we're doing the sequel to that to the
ladies of Liberty for children and so
that's the next project and that when I
can handle hi it's good to see you nice
to see you thank you for come many years
I have admired you my question is did
Clara Barton have any connection with
just free slaves you know I don't have
she she was an abolitionist whispered
women she was an abolitionist but I
don't have letters of hers along those
lines and it didn't seem to be a major
issue with her
it is a major issue well to her I'm
saying but the but there were quite a
few women who did there was a woman
named Josephine Giddings I'm talking
about Clara Barton yeah I'm not really
interesting here okay she did she was an
abolitionist and she it was a cause that
she that she was concerned about but it
wasn't which it wasn't her major
occupation yes yes
hello thank you for speaking I wondered
how you got access to all these letters
was that difficult well right here we
have Lara from the manuscript division
of the Library of Congress then that's a
good place to go the so when I did
family mothers it was much harder for a
couple of reasons first of all they we
were dealing in the 18th century not the
19th but also a lot of people felt that
I was a mere journalist and what was I
doing
rooting around in history I was supposed
to deal with today and and so I people
were not as forthcoming as they became
after that book came out and once once I
published founding mothers and people
sort of saw what I was up to I started
getting a lot more help from historical
societies university libraries and
historic homes and the Library of
Congress was always helpful but so that
is those are the main places you go
what's happened with modern technology
is that someone a helpful soul will scan
a lot of the letters and and send them
to you so you don't have to travel and
go through through it that way even once
I get them and that's her fee which is
fair enough you know once I get them
though what I have then is scanned 19th
century handwriting letters that are
written this way in this way because
everybody was saving paper and I can't
read them very well so I had to hire
somebody to help me read them because
they they were quite deciphering but
that's that's kind of a treatment itself
you know because then you're you're
coming upon unexpected things and for
instance was Virginia clay Clopton which
was a second husband's name she the
woman who wrote the bell of the 50s it's
kind of a a cheery funny flirtatious
book
she wrote a diary about the same period
which is farce darker and it had not
been published and I got that from Duke
University library the David Rubenstein
librarian at Duke University well
there's not met four people or five foot
two coming closer to sort of your
parents or my parents generation how is
their way to handle Korea and World War
two given that the letters are so many
so all over the world because we're
losing the history of the war at home
yeah well there have been some some good
World War two women's letters books
written we were in this war to is one of
them and there's a book about the women
Air Service Pilots the wasp again from
their own families but you know I really
don't want to write about the 20th
century I lived through most of it and
or at least hit more than half of it and
and I I kind of like dead people long
dead people and although even they can
be a problem I mean I was talking to
some group about family mothers and I
got some descendant of someone all
outraged and you know saying that that I
had portrayed her ancestor in an
unsavory light give it a rest you know
it's been several hundred years now and
she was actually a delightful woman that
she was a little bit of a [ __ ] and um
but um there you are
you know good morning thank you so much
for speaking I was interested in your
comment that you never had any intention
about writing about the Civil War you
know being a southerner and having that
affiliation how has gone through going
through this process changed that for
you or has it and how you kind of
associate or preconceptions that you had
of being a southerner no I mean I'm a
southerner but I I must say this since I
wrote this book all of a sudden my
southern Confederate Army ancestors are
coming out of the woodwork and one of
their uniforms showed up and so they and
I you know I I can deal with those
people the the fact is is that I loved
growing up in the south and and I have
tremendous a tremendous sense of being
at home in the south but I also know all
of the problems and and would never in a
million years try to pretend that they
did not exist you know I grew up as the
child of civil rights supporter from the
deep south in the 1960s and it was a
very a cross was burned on our lawn I
mean you know it was a very tumultuous
time and so I would never in a million
years say that it was it was not as
violent and as
as wrongheaded and as immoral as it was
the war itself as I said at the
beginning to me aside from the fact that
it was so such a horrendous loss of life
and of course the people who lost the
most were in this out I mean the area
was ravaged for decades to come but the
the fact is is that it was such a
failure of the ability of politicians to
do what they're supposed to do which is
to bring the country together and and
it's a it's a true object lesson of
where we don't want to be in politics of
people not able to come together and do
the right thing for the good of the
country and and that's something worth
learning over and
[Music]
all right I'm getting there's a hook
over here it's a very it's a very subtle
hook it says wrap up so I will wrap up
I'm very very grateful to all of you for
coming I'm going immediately downstairs
to sign this book I really hope that you
do read it because you will love getting
to know these women and I do think it's
important that we do know all of our
history the history of our women thank
you so so much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're going to go down
[Music]
and for the fifteenth year in a row book
TV is live at the National Book Festival
being held at the Washington Convention
Center you are just listening to Cokie
Roberts speak by the way miss Roberts
will be our in-depth guest in December
she'll be taking your calls on all of
her books coming up next in the history
and biography room will be Joseph Ellis
talking about his most recent book the
quartet orchestrating the second
American Revolution
well book TV is at the convention center
and we are down in the lobby on a set
and we are joined now by Jean Theo
Harris who is a professor at Brooklyn
College and the author of the rebellious
life of mrs. Rosa Parks Jean Theo Harris
prior to December 1st 1955 was Rosa
Parks rebellious absolutely and her
rebellious spirit really starts as a
young person as a kid for instance she
grows up in a home with her grandparents
and her mother her grandfather after
World War two there's this uptake of
Clan violence in fine level Alabama her
grandfather will sit out at night with
his shotgun and a young six-year-old
Rosa Parks will sit with him another
time a white bully pushes her and she
pushes that right she believes that she
shouldn't have to be pushed her
political life starts when she meets who
she describes the first real activist
she ever met and that's Raymond parks
they will get married in 1932 and she
will join him organizing around the
Scottsboro case so that's 1932 and for
the next 20 years she will be active
she'll join the n-double-a-cp in 1943
for the next ten years will help to lead
the Montgomery and double-a-c-p
into becoming a more activist chapter
with Edie Nixon doing voter registration
working on legal cases both legal
lynching cases but also trying to get
justice for
women who have been victims of sexual
violence so by December 1st 1955 Rosa
Parks is a seasoned rebel if you will
was December 1st 1955 the bus sit down
was that planned no it was not planned
but it is the process both in terms of
her life a kind of culmination of again
many acts of rebellion certainly
Montgomery's black community is thinking
about filing a suit this is a year after
Brown versus Board of Education so we're
in a different legal climate they've
been talking about the need to challenge
bus segregation this is also not the
first act she's not the first person
arrested on the bus in the decade after
World War two you see a kind of trickle
of people refusing to give up their seat
getting arrested in 1944 a woman by the
name of viola white refuses to give up
her seat is arrested starts to pursue
her legal case police rape her daughter
there's a series of cases again 1954
with brown offers a new opportunity and
as you may know in March of 1955 a
fifteen year old by the name of
Claudette Colvin refuses to give up her
seat on the bus at first it seems like
maybe this will be the case of the
community begins to galvanize two things
happen one the judge throws out the
segregation charge in Claudette Colvin's
case and second the community doesn't
fully stand behind Colvin they see her
as too young too feisty so when I say
it's not planned Rosa Parks is not a
freedom writer she doesn't get on the
bus to make a stand but it also is not
spontaneous it doesn't just come out of
nowhere Rosa Parks had also made stands
on the bus before December 1st 1955
one of the things that called her was
many bus drivers would make black people
pay in the front and then get off the
bus and reboard in the back she refused
to do that and she'd been thrown off the
bus by both this bus driver who will
arrest who will have her arrested and
other bus drivers who considered her
uppity for not being willing to do that
so this is not her first active bus
resistance but on December 1st 1955
she's coming home from work it's about 6
o'clock at night she actually lets a bus
pass by because it's too crowded goes to
the drugstore buys a few things boards
the bus sits in the middle section the
middle section is a bit of a no-man's
land in that black people this is not
the white section and over and over she
makes clear that she's not sitting in
the white section there are a lot of
myths that she sits in the white section
that's not true she's sitting in the
beginning of the middle section the
middle section black people could sit
there but if she would put it on the
whim of the driver could be asked to
give up their seat now the Third's
stop after she gets on the bus fills up
and one white man is left standing and
the bus driver notices this the bus
drivers name is James bike
and he tells the people in Rosa Parks's
row because for this one white man to
sit down all four people in this row
will have to get up and he asked them to
get up no one moves he asks again more
forceful y'all better make it light on
yourself and the other three people
reluctantly according to Rosa Parks get
up and she as she puts it pushed as far
as she could be pushed that if she got
up she would be consenting to this
treatment she said and she did not
consent she thinks about Emmett Till in
this moment the young 14 year old who'd
been lynched in Mississippi she thinks
about her grandfather and she refuses
and so she actually slides she lets the
man sitting next to her get by her and
she slides over to the window and
refuses the bus driver says well I'm
gonna have you arrested and she says
well you may do that so the bus driver
gets off to call the police right
doesn't have a cell phone and I think we
could think about what's happening in
that moment right because she's sitting
there I think those of us who's been on
the bus when somebody makes a scene
right know what people do right people
are grumbling people are getting off the
bus the police officers get on the bus
and I think many of us think about Rosa
Parks being quiet right
and Rosa Parks is certainly a shy
reserved person but Rosa Parks is not
quiet in key moments and when the police
officers get on the bus and they asked
her why she didn't move she says back
why do you push us around so I do think
Rosa Parks in many moments challenges
both in her body but in also with her
voice the kind of systems of inequality
in this country and then she is arrested
well I want to go to the teaching of
history because as children we all
learned that Rosa Parks sat on the bus
in the white section and quiet this is
what you write in your book the
rebellious life of mrs. Rosa Parks just
as turn-of-the-century reconstruction
histories held up good black people as
deferential and happy so - so does the
incessant celebration of parks as quiet
and not angry
I mean I think we learn about her she
has a kind of on the one hand right
she's incredibly celebrated and honored
on the other hand we hear about one day
when Rosa Parks had a lifetime of
activism both in Montgomery
but the purposes we'll have to leave
Montgomery in 1957 and she will spend
the second half of her life as an
activist in Detroit fighting the racism
of the Jim Crow North and she will
continue to do that Rosa Parks will call
mark Malcolm X her personal hero she
will be active against the war in
Vietnam she will be active against South
African apartheid you are showing a
picture one of my favorites in the book
of a of an older Rosa Parks protesting
outside the South African embassy she
will continue to the end of her life
saying the struggle isn't over there is
much kind of injustice in this country
and she will kind of be
and have resolved to keep fighting and
yet I think the way Rosa Parks is taught
is it's taught as this problem we solved
in the past when the actual Rosa Parks
said there's much more work to be done
how did you do your research on this
book where were the papers I had to do a
lot of digging I did I went to all sorts
of archives I did all sorts of oral
history interviews in part because a
part of Rosa Parks's papers were caught
up in a dispute over her estate
Guernsey's auction had gotten the papers
to sell with all of her effects they
languished in New York for about a
decade until this summer Howard Buffett
made an incredible donation bought them
and recently gave them to the Library of
Congress and in February they opened so
they are remarkable the Library of
Congress is open to anyone who wants to
visit people should go see them you can
actually sort of read letters between
Rosa Parks and her husband and her
mother and you can see some of Rosa
Parks's political writings you can hear
her voice talking about why she did what
she did so I very much recommend that so
you're spending a little more time at
the Library of Congress absolutely
absolutely
Jean Theo Harris the rebellious life of
mrs. Rosa Parks is the name of the book
and you're watching book TV on c-span 2
live from the 15th annual National Book
Festival this is the 15th year in a row
that we have been live at this festival
this is the second year in a row it's
been held inside we're at the convention
center for many years it was on the
National Mall here in Washington we're
also broadcasting live from the history
and biography room and we're going to
take you up there now the next offer
you're going to hear from is historian
Joseph Ellis his most recent book is
called the quartet orchestrating the
second American Revolution and you can
see they're all getting all set up there
he's going to be in conversation with
Carlisle groups David Rubenstein who is
a financier of the National Book
Festival
and this will begin in just a minute
after that Jan Jarboe Russell will be
talking about World War two internment
camps will have Collins today with David
McCullough Tom Brokaw Evan Thomas on
Richard Nixon Buzz Aldrin you'll have a
chance to talk with all of those authors
authors throughout the day so stick with
us full schedule available at book TV
org or follow us on Twitter at book TV
or check out our Facebook page
facebook.com slash book TV this is book
TVs live coverage in just a minute
professor and historian Joseph Ellis
good morning my name is Sue Segal I'm
the director of development at the
Library of Congress it's my distinct
honor this morning to introduce the
gentleman who was most responsible for
making this National Book Festival
possible our lead benefactor the
co-founder and co-ceo of the Carlyle
Group the co-chairman of the National
Book Festival David M Rubenstein
honored and privileged today to have one
of the leading authors and scholars of
the Revolutionary War period in our
country Joseph Ellis Joseph Ellis is a
person who actually grew up in
Washington went the Gonzaga high went to
William and Mary alright Gonzaga High
grads went to William and Mary then got
his PhD at Yale and spoke spent most of
his academic career teaching at Mount
Holyoke College where he was the Dean of
the faculty at one point and down
professor he's also taught at Williams
at West Point and at University of
Massachusetts at Amherst and on the side
when he hasn't been teaching he's been
writing best-selling books among them
are biographies of John Adams George
Washington
Jaffrey Thomas Jefferson that's book on
Thomas Jefferson American sinks won the
National Book Award and his book on the
Revolutionary brothers are the founding
brothers the revolutionary generation
won the Pulitzer Prize in 2001 most
recently he has written a book that I
actually have here the quartet that has
been for ten weeks on the knack New York
Times bestseller list it's about what he
would call the second American
Revolution the revolution that began
early in 1787 not 1776 so let's get into
that but before we do that thank you
very much for coming dr. Ellis why did
you decide to focus your academic career
on the Revolutionary War period you
could have picked so many different
areas what it wasn't about this area
that was interesting to you yeah I do
seem obsessed don't I and well they
asked Willy Sutton back in the 50s